my wife uh last year i think it was last
year uh
not this year's uh october the last
october she played a surprise birthday
party for me
huge okay uh event it was supposed to be
100 people and
[ __ ] [ __ ] burlesque dancers and
then
geraldo passed away on the night that
the party was supposed to take place
and so she that was his way oh right so
she had to cancel it and make it
you know literally the last second
rearrange everything and make it to a
small restaurant and
she could only afford a couple you know
like a
small amount of people she wanted to
roast you she wanted us to go up and
roast you a little bit and
it was going to be huge a huge yeah and
uh
she told all my friends patrice called
me up
uh days before two days before the party
and when bobby and i was like what's up
he goes i gotta i gotta tell you
something man
and i'm like what's up man he goes you
know your wife's playing a surprise
party for you right
and i'm like what what the [ __ ] and he
goes i just want to let you know man
because i don't like surprises
he goes i don't know if you like
surprises like that i don't know if you
like that type of [ __ ] so
i'm just and i go maybe you should have
opened with do you like surprises
and i would have said yes i love [ __ ]
surprises
i'm a lonely piece of [ __ ] i love
surprises
he was looking out for you
i [ __ ] knew you knew when you walked
in i was like he's not surprised
timmy was one of my first white friends
like in my life
man good dude too he moved to silver
spring
from utah of all places i guess his
family was affiliated with that
mormon church they got down there and me
and him used to hang out
and one day i was at his house we were
just hanging out and timmy says dave
why don't you stay for dinner tonight i
said oh man
i'd love to but i can't if i'm not home
before dark my mother will kill me
that was a lot my mother had several
jobs i hadn't seen her like three or
four days
and the only reason i lied to timmy was
because at that point in my life
it was my experience that white dinner
wasn't delicious
[Applause]
i'd rather go home and fry some bologna
or some [ __ ] like that
but then old timmy threw me a curveball
i wasn't expecting he said oh it's too
bad you can't stay dave cause um
mama made stovetop stuffing
i said what the [ __ ] stovetop
oh hold on [ __ ] let me make some phone
calls real quick
i had seen that commercial so many times
i had dreamt of getting my hands on some
of that stovetop stuffing
and finally i met a [ __ ] that
actually had a box of stovetop in the
house
i couldn't miss this opportunity so i
pretended to call my mother
and then i came back and i said timmy
timmy you're not gonna believe this
great news
mom said i can stay and he said
fantastic he said why don't you come
with me
and we'll help set the table and then we
can say the blessing i had
no interest in setting this
motherfucker's table or
saying these crazy-ass mormon prayers
i just wanted that god damn stuffing
so i told me i said you know what i'd
love to help but let me go wash my hands
first
my plan was simple wash my hands slowly
and by the time i'm done the table will
be set
the blessing will be said and all that
there will be left to do
is heat went to the bathroom
i washed my hands very slowly i must
have been in there for about 10 minutes
and suddenly one of his mothers came to
the door
[Applause]
[Music]
she was like hi david right
i said yes ma'am she said timmy tells me
that you're
planning on staying for dinner i said i
hope that's not a problem ma'am
she says no it's no problem in fact we'd
love to have you it's just
that we weren't expecting company and
i'm afraid
there's not enough stove top stuffing
for everybody
so i kicked her in the [ __ ] bam ladies
and gentlemen
i told you i'm dope [ __ ] i told you i
was gonna say and you still didn't see
it coming
and that's why i make the big bucks
remember we took some mushrooms one time
to a uh
party in high school because i grew up
in an area where you could just get
mushroom i mean
psychedelic mushrooms grew on everything
they grow on your [ __ ] cousin's back
if you took a long enough nap you know
they grew everywhere out there oh they
grew everywhere because everybody had
something [ __ ] in their yard
and then it would rain every single day
for about a half hour right wow
so it was just i mean you see people
picking them and eating them and
families out there enjoying them in the
afternoon i mean it was everybody was oh
it was psychedelic heaven
so no i took that bag of mushrooms to
that party right and a bunch of people
ate them who'd never had them before
uh-oh and then we played a game of
hide-and-go-seek right i was like oh no
dude you hide in another dimension i was
like
i'll count you guys go hide right oh no
and i never went to [ __ ] look for it
[Laughter]
that was the end of the head bro this
boy timothy i've never seen that dude
[Music]
again
[Music]
you're a celebrity of any sort people
want things from you
especially terminally ill children
so anyways there was a make-a-wish uh
foundation and this
child wanted me you want to come to snl
natural
and and then watch me throughout the
week and see how
an idea became a sketch so i said okay
that's a wonderful idea and uh i
talked to him at his bedside and i got
everybody else to scram you know
and uh i was saying how
touched i was that he he wanted to do
that
and then he said i don't want to do that
i just made that up i haven't
liked snl since bill murray left
what do you want me for he said well do
you have your canadian citizenship still
and i said yes i'm canadian
you know and he said well that helps my
wish
my wish is to kill a baby seal
so we took him you know me and my buddy
uh we went to gander newfoundland where
we uh
where we uh uh got the the services of
uh
edward mcclintock a cod fisherman
and he took us to the flow and uh
and uh we we found the um we you know
and a boy had a did not terrible cough
you know
and uh edward mcclintock said he's not
going to make it through the north
atlantic
and i said it but his final wish you
know but i worried about the boy you
know
so many pills
but we tried i tried to entertain him uh
we would sit and we'd look
the sky is so beautiful and limitless
when you get to the
these super northern places and we look
at the
clouds the boy and i and
we try to find figures in them you know
like i go that clown looks like a
half-eaten
pickle
the boy had not learned that life was
about food yet
so he saw other things you know he would
go look there's a man with a beard and
i'd say i don't see it he goes
right see where the that's his mouth and
then that's his chin i go yes it is a
man with a beard
right you are and you know and i go what
about that one it's an alligator he go i
instantly i see this an alligator
so we both saw an alligator and on it
went so
uh finally uh we get to the
we hear the the
odd noise i'd never heard that uh edward
mcclintock said harp seal
yeah baby harp
uh so he said oh god thank god because i
was getting we've been on this
sea for a couple days and uh
we go and and then you we heard gunshots
and uh edward mcclintock said damn
punk's from saint john's with the
revolvers
that's not how you kill a seal
and we said well how do you kill him and
he produced uh
a rucksack and out of the rucksack was
this
medieval looking sort of thing it was
called a hack-a-pick
like a pic and uh edward mcclintock
gave instructions to the boy and he said
uh he said a a sealed skull is as thin
as a shadow by
ah strike him with this hacker pick
directly above the eyes
and watch as they go glassy
so the boy ran away
no he didn't run away man he ran towards
ran toward this
harp seal or where the baby harp
and um and me
and edward mcclintock and my buddy stood
there
and he had such strength suddenly
this child and he struck as hard as he
could
and the blood came out as the it was
so red with the white behind it you know
just this
fountain of blood and so most of it hit
the boy's
face and went in his mouth and it was
almost like the life of the seal
itself was transferring
there to the child and then me and my
friend and edward mcclintock
we just stood and watched this wicked
miracle unfold
and on our way back we were all
depressed and
we couldn't get the image out of our
mind except for the boy
who sang gay songs
i gave him his pills he threw him in the
north atlantic
he didn't want the bills and we went
back and
a miracle had happened the boy was free
of his uh uh disease it was like a it
was in the new york newspapers
at the time this was about 18 years ago
and uh he he he got a small measure of
fame for it and he
he got to go to gracie mansion and he
met the mayor
and uh he was on the donahue program
cured phil donahue yeah there were other
there were other people with him that
had been cured and so forth he didn't
he didn't remain a secret of how he was
cured
but uh and it was barely mentioned
a year later when he was struck by a
city bus and killed
so anyways is that